this morning we have an exclusive
broadcast interview with brianna
taylor's boyfriend his name is kenneth
walker
he spoke at length about the early
morning police raid that killed taylor
back in march
walker and taylor were sleeping when
louisville police raided her apartment
looking for a drug
suspect very early in the morning now he
insists
that he asked he and brianna both asked
he said who is at the door
but police never identified themselves
the police say
that they did walker says he fired one
shot at the officers with a legally
licensed gun
because he thought they were intruders
who did you think was at the door if
you're saying who is it who is it and
they're not answering
because it certainly doesn't sound like
a friendly knock i didn't have a clue
that's why i grabbed the gun
yeah didn't have a clue i mean if it was
the police at the door and they just
said with where the police
me or brianna didn't have a reason at
all not to open the door and
see what they wanted but did it ever
cross your mind a heavy knock like that
maybe it's the police that's why i never
thought it was the police because why
would the police be coming here
that's a very good question you know he
said to me if you heard a heavy knock at
the door would you think must be the
police
which which i have to say anthony i
never thought of it that way i would
think that it was somebody who was
coming to
give me heart do me arm said no it never
occurred to either of us that it was the
police
because in their minds they weren't
doing anything that would warrant police
coming there
also neither one of them had any kind of
criminal records
involving drugs violent history no drugs
no money were found in the apartment
and you expect the police to say open up
it's the police
and many exactly right and many
witnesses say they did not say that
there is one witness who
who says they did there is one witness
who changed his story
yes right now says that they did it's a
very confusing
well it's not so confusing to kenneth
walker who by the way his story has
never
changed from day one about what happened
that night
you can see more of our exclusive
broadcast interview with kenneth walker
tomorrow
on cbs this morning